so I've been using and loving the
Microsoft band too for a while now but
despite all of its great qualities which
I talked about in the review Microsoft
does seem to have some quality control
issues I had to return the device about
five times it broke again and I thought
that's it I'm gonna try something new so
I bought myself the garmin vivoactive HR
and i must say it's rather splendid
when I first got my hands on the
vivoactive HR is actually a little bit
disappointed it feels a little flimsy
and plasticky in the hands and the
screen is very dim certainly a step down
from the Microsoft band 2 and also not
half as clear as the promotional
materials made it look on the plus side
the full-color display is a bit fancier
than the Fitbit surge at least and it's
nice that you can download custom watch
faces - it's comfy enough as well though
little on a large side to be truly
practical but a fitness tracker
shouldn't be a fashion statement anyways
and this device has got it where it
counts the starters it comes packed with
all the sensors you might need including
the heart rate monitor altimeter compass
GPS pedometer etc and these all allow
you to track everything you'd expect
such as your daily activity your sleep
quality and all manner of activities
like running swimming cycling
weightlifting skiing walking and more
while many of these features are fairly
standard on fitness trackers these days
oh I like about the vivoactive hey
Chou's that nothing's left out there no
compromises for example many devices
like the Microsoft band 2 and Fitbit
surge aren't waterproof the vivoactive
HR is safe up to 5 meters meaning you
can swim with it other devices leave out
the GPS making them poor choices as
running watches or they are very good
for weight lifting the gear fit - for
example doesn't let you use the
heartrate monitor during workouts the
vivoactive hey charlie other hand
doesn't make those kind of compromises
and another example of this is the
battery life which can last up to 7 days
on a single charge even when using the
GPS and other things regularly and that
GPS actually gets an upgrade as well
seeing as the beaver active HR is
capable of using GLONASS to connect more
quickly and get more accurate location
data this is Garmin better known for
their Sat Navs after all all this is
made possible thanks to a great heart
rate sensor while no wrist worn heart
rate sensor is going to be perfect this
one does take a lot of readings and
seems to be at the front of the pack for
accuracy there is also the option to
pair it with a more accurate Garmin
chess strap if you want to more
importantly it uses a smart update
frequency which is something you don't
hear that much about this means it won't
just check your heart rate once every 10
minutes regardless of what you're doing
throughout the day and that allows it to
give more accurate information regarding
your calories burned it doesn't miss any
quick runs to the shop for example or
sexy pillow fights for those who like
tracking calories or macros this makes
big difference and gives a much more
reliable calculation the garment a
percolates all this data in a very
comprehensive manner to giving you
screens and screens to read through when
you're done training I particularly
enjoyed seeing my top speed stride
length and cadence after a run that said
a few things are noticeably absent such
as a score for overall sleep quality
which is implicit not explicit or VA to
max on the other hand is particularly
effective at motivating you to moved
that's thanks to a step target that
adjusts the better suit your lifestyle
and a move bar that fills up the longer
you remain inactive the streak of days
where you meet your calorie goal is also
clever the OCD in you will want to work
extra hard not to break that streak but
where all that data falls down isn't
just how obtuse it is seriously the
Garmin Connect app looks like it was
designed by someone on hard drugs
nothing is we expect it to be there are
two separate ways to look at your sleep
which showed different information
calories burned are surprisingly hard to
find both for each day and after workout
it's not a problem if you're willing to
go digging but it's hardly intuitive and
it's a bit of a pain when even months
later you're still struggling to
remember where you need to go to find
certain information also disappointing
is how clearly aimed at runners the
devices while it does support weight
lifting insists on telling you how much
distance you've covered as the main
metric when you finish the workout and
of course that figure is normally a fat
zero which isn't exactly motivating it
provides just as much information in
this regard as the competition but it
still feels like a bit of an
afterthought rather than one of the
intended purposes what's great about the
software though is the SmartWatch stuff
this is a fitness tracker first in a
SmartWatch second but the ability to get
notifications on your wrist is something
I've grown used to with the Microsoft
fans and it's nice to find it present
and correct here better still have a
number of different apps available to
install which can greatly expand the
watch as capabilities these include
music controls a stargazing app maps a
calculator that missing vo to metric and
even flappy birds it's an absolutely
rubbish version of flappy birds sure but
it's definitely neat for showing what
the device is capable of overall then
this is by no means a perfect device and
the UI screen brightness and build
quality could all do with some work but
as a reliable way to track all kinds of
different fitness data for days on end
without a charge it's quite possibly
the best option out there